beautiful person is Jennifer Garner
looks as gorgeous as ever on the cover
of People magazine's new beautiful issue
2019 the cover was revealed on The Ellen
Show and Jen revealed she was
embarrassed list now a magazine for AARP
Jennifer Garner is the star next door
because she really has that vibe of a
woman you feel like you know and you
love and she's also pretty gorgeous but
in a very natural very down-to-earth way
and it's inside and out she has a great
spirit and she sees Beauty holistically
and that was just perfect for her on the
cover the actor sits on a car rocking a
floral outfit and boots for the cover
shoot inside the mom of three discusses
her style choices admitting she never
felt pretty in school well I was so not
one of the pretty girls that I just
bypassed insecurities and didn't see
myself as attractive at all it was not
part of my life not only is she pretty
she's funny as heck she also addressed
tabloid rumors that she's pregnant in
that cute just to be clear again I'm 47
we've wrapped it up
Gardner adds her family kept her
grounded and taught her that looks were
not important quote I felt good about
myself back then that is the lucky trick
looks we're a big deal in my family I
don't think my parents ever said you're
pretty and so we just didn't think about
it that wasn't something that was
important to her family it was more
about who she was as a person now garner
focuses on her own family as mom of 13
year old violent ten-year-old Serafina
and seven year old Samuel with
ex-husband Ben Affleck life right now is
about her daughters and about work but
Jen isn't just celebrating most
beautiful it's also the 15th anniversary
of 13 going on 30 she shared a sweet
heartfelt post dedicated not only to the
film as a whole but a specific a slumber
party scene
quote I loved my day with a slumber
party crew they danced with abandon and
reminded me of the power of just saying
yes to being in a group to vulnerability
to wearing a bra over your clothes
imagine if every thirteen-year-old had
an opportunity to dance and feel
beautiful like the girls in this film I
am proud of all of you by the way
there's like four Marvel characters in
this movie
Mark Ruffalo the Hulk Andy Serkis Clow
brie Larson who is Captain Marvel and
Jennifer Garner herself who was actually
Elektra that's your fun fact for the day
but you should spend the rest of your
day on Jennifer Garner's Instagram
because it's a gosh-darn delight you'll
realize why she got this prestigious
honor until next time I'm ash Gosselin
you